des hôpitaux au bord de la saturation et
un nombre de cas positifs qui ne faiblit
pas au cours des deux dernières semaines
le portugal a été le pays au monde ayant
signalé le plus grand nombre de
contagion et de décès dus aux copies 19
en rapport avec sa population
seul lanclas britannique de gibraltar a
dépassé le triste eurocorps portugais
clairement les choses se passent très
mal
nous avons observé une croissance
exponentielle des nouveaux cas et cela
amène à de nouvelles hospitalisations
qui à leur tour provoque une pression
gigantesque sur le service national de
santé
cette tension va sûrement durer
plusieurs semaines cette recrudescence
pousse les services hospitaliers à leurs
limites
les experts tablent sur un pic
épidémique qui pourraient être atteints
mi février
une projection qui fait planer le
spectre d'un possible effondrement du
système de santé à l'hôpital militaire
de lisbonne des centaines de soldats ont
passé des semaines à transformer chaque
espace disponible en salle kovy 19 au
cours des neuf premiers mois nous avons
triplé notre capacité mais avec tout ce
qui s'est passé le mois dernier nous
avons été obligés de tripler ce qui
était déjà une triple capacité un grand
effort de notre part car nous avons dû
mettre en place une opération à grande
échelle pour faire face à toutes les
demandes que nous avons reçues pour
soutenir les hôpitaux de la région de
lisbonne le portugal subit le double
effet de l'assouplissement des
restrictions de circulation et des
rassemblements à noël cette période a
coïncidé avec l'apparition du variant
angles est et sud africain plus
récemment des experts ont reproché au
gouvernement de ne pas avoir réagi plus
rapidement les vols à destination et en
provenance du brésil un pays ayant des
liens étroits avec le portugal ou une
autre variante inquiétante a été détecté
ne seront interdits qu'à partir de ce
vendredi face à la situation le
gouvernement a annoncé la limitation des
déplacements à l'étranger sauf cas
exceptionnel pendant la prochaine
quinzaine des sorties de citoyens
nationaux par voie aérienne terrestre ou
maritime seront limités depuis le 15
janvier les quelques 10 millions de
portugais sont soumis à un deuxième
confinement général
pour tenter de maîtriser l'explosion de
cas de couronnes un virus